my nephew jesse is coming in on the
flight I'm bringing the young gun in hey
Jesse how's it going
I am Jesse Moore and I am from Fairbanks
Alaska I'm here because my auntie
happened to get another accident and I
am here to help her with anything she
happens to need I know you're probably
tired you're probably hungry but um I've
got bigwig people coming in in the next
few days so I've got to get that water
line okay
get it rolling and I don't want to
[ __ ] be the ante and but you know
let's get the word yeah hold this while
I undo this I've got to do what I can
try to keep kavik going there is
absolutely zero running water in camp
the only water running in camp is in the
river so this absurd system is how I get
my water we're gonna suck it out of the
river up through this piping pump it
through the filters into the water house
take this side in it's gonna go in here
got water feel it here you got water
Jessie you level that out I'm gonna
check the other side of it see if
there's water coming out
all right I can already hear it I got me
some water
all right I've got everything you got
everything done in there that I can do
and the big test is will it come out of
the scope yeah
I've got water
how we are
we have water